c'est en mode commando que pascal
prépare ses entraînements sur la loire
officier de l'armée de l'air il a gardé
de ses années de soldats engagés en zone
de conflit
l'intensité dans sa démarche aujourd'hui
il s'agit de battre un record
donc mon projet c'est de faire une
descente de la loire sur la quasi
intégralité depuis roanne jusqu'à
saint-nazaire ce qui fait 750 km l'hiver
prochain et si possible d'établir un
record de descente de cinq jours
peut-être moins si vraiment les
conditions aux souris une aventure
ligérienne qui s'inscrit dans un
parcours de reconstruction après un
syndrome de stress post traumatique
liées à des opérations de combat ce raid
a pour but de le réconcilier avec
lui-même et ça passe par une aventure
hivernale
le courant est plus puissant en hiver
pour un record c'est le favorable mais
c'est aussi un contact plus fort avec la
nature plus intense puisque là l'hiver
la loire est beaucoup plus sauvage
il n'y a personne sur l'eau personnes
sur les rives des conditions rigoureuses
donc le froid la pluie
et ça ça impose de sortir plus d'énergie
plus de force morale que l'été mais
c'est vrai que je me retrouve dans dans
ce contact intense avec les éléments à
ce corps à corps et c'est ça qui me fait
le plus de bien
formation achats de matériels et
repérage devront être financées par du
sponsoring
nom de code de l'opération silver
aventure